[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les émotions sont engrammés dans le
corps quand on libère le corps on libère
les émotions et bien plus encore on
libère la douleur du
corps à votre avis qu'est-ce que ça peut
libérer
d'autres far
[Musique]
Daniel Diamono
donité bambé
donité
bambé cette chanson j'en comprends pas
du tout le sens mais j'adore l'histoire
de cette femme qui se transforme en
anèe certaines soirées ma mère nous
raconte dans son lit des contes
sénégalais ma mère c'est une artiste
elle vient en France alors qu'elle est
mécanicienne dans la couture elle est
douée
elle devient costumière et quelques
années après elle entre à l'école de
cinéma pour devenir réalisatrice et
scénariste je suis issue d'une famille
nombreuse et nous vivons tous avec ma
mère dans un
appartement avec mes sœurs nous
inventons une multitude de jeux notre
jeu préféré c'est le jeu des petits
bonhommes on choisit chacune à tour de
rôle des personnages et on invente un
tas
d'histoires et moi seul je danse je
danse dans ma chambre en écoutant des
musiques à la
radio quand je danse il y a quelque
chose qui s'anime en
moi j'ai l'impression de vivre est-ce
que vous vous rappelez quand on
enregistrait nos chansons préférées avec
un radio cassette moi je mettais des
morceaux de papier ou du scotch et on
appuyait sur la touche REC et ben moi je
me fais ma playlist et je sélectionne
destin de Céline Dion pour créer ma
première
chorégraphie tel est mon
destin tel est mon
destin je vais mon
chemin ainsi passe mes heures au
rythmebattement de mon cœur battement de
mon
cœur désolé je suis tellement fire de
moi que je vaux la montrer à ma mère
mais
j'hésite comment va-t-elle
réagir parce qu'à la maison le cadre est
assez strict les règles c'est les règles
et nous devons y obéir et surtout je ne
dois pas montrer ma
sensibilité surtout
pas ma mère veut notre réussite entre
les devoirs scolaires et les tâches
ménagères nous sortons très peuse à
l'extérieur c'est même cette dureté cet
ennui qui développe ainsi ma créativité
je prends mon courage à demain je
l'invite ainsi que mes frères et sœurs à
ma
représentation quand je
danse je suis en connexion avec la
mélodie avec les
[Musique]
mots je me sens bien
elle est tellement fière et tellement
conquise qu'elle veut m'inscrire à des
cours de danse ça y est je suis prête
pour mon premier cours de danse
classique mais du haut de mes 10 ans je
comprends très vite je ne suis pas la
bienvenue finalement elle m'inscrit à
des cours de hip hop je suis trop
contente parce que de 1 je sors de chez
moi et de deux je découvre un autre
[Musique]
univers
et j'en pratique 5 années mon prof
s'appelle Jimy je le trouve trop beau et
j'adore ses cours en groupe je ressens
un tel sentiment d'appartenance que je
me dépasse et je progresse très
rapidement à 13 ans je donne mes
premiers cours de hiphop aux enfants de
mon
quartier loin de la maison je me sens
vivre je me sens
exister dès lors
tel mon destin la danse va suivre les
battements de mon
[Musique]
cœur sauf que mon cœur va mal il va très
mal parce qu'à 15 ans je fais de
l'hypertension artérielle à 15 ans ça se
passe très mal à la maison et selon ma
mère je suis trop dans
l'opposition alors elle me met à
l'internat elle m'inscrit au lycée Louis
Bascan à rambouiller je sais je sais pas
si vous connaissez dès le premier jour
je me sens très vite chez moi je suis
bien accueilli et nous sommes comme une
petite famille nous mangeons ensemble
nous dormons ensemble nous nous
disputons nous nous réconcilions et nous
régolons énormément ils aiment se moquer
de moi parce que j'ai un côté assez
extravagant et original j'y reste 2 ans
dans cet internat et ce sont les
meilleurs année de toute ma
scolarité cet internat a la partie
ularité d'accueillir des jeunes avec un
trouble visuel je côtoie donc des
personnes malvoyantes et non
voyant je rencontre aussi des jeunes
sans handicap certains sont là parce
qu'il manquent de cadrage et d'autres
ont des relations conflictuelles ou
difficiles avec leur famille bref chacun
a sa difficulté que ce soit dans leur
corps ou dans leur esprit c'est engramé
là quelque part dans leur être
à votre avis qu'est-ce que je fais de
mon temps
libre je danse je découvre la danse
contemporaine le mercredi après-midi à
l'association sportive du lycée c'est
encore un autre
univers je fais mon premier duo avec
Guillaume
d'ailleurs il participe avec d'autres au
cours de hiphop que je donne le soir à
l'internat après les
cours aujourd'hui je comprends l'impact
que ça a eu sur eux et sur
moi pour mes camarades ils peuvent déjà
relâcher la pression du quotidien ils
s'expriment davantage avec leur corps
ils apprennent à
s'affirmer pour ma part j'ai
suffisamment de confiance en moi pour
transmettre ma pratique la danse
restaure l'estime que j'ai de moi et
renforce mon lien avec les
autres la danse restaure l'estime que
j'ai de moi et renforce mon lien avec
les
autres c'est là que commence clairement
ma métamorphose j'ai 17 ans je suis au
lycée ma métamorphose commence ce qui a
été abîmé à un moment de notre vie peut
se réparer à un
autre ce qui qui a été abîmé à un moment
de notre vie peut se réparer à un
autre et maintenant la danse c'est mon
ikigaï comme le disent mes proches je
suis faite pour ça et je suis utile aux
autres par ce
biaislà je danse je chorégraphie je
transmet et j'en fais même un
tê aujourd'hui je danse par envie je
m'exprime par la danse et je m'exprime
grâce à la
danse avant je dansais par
survie parce que j'en avais besoin
besoin pour réparer pour reconstruire
pour désengramer ce que mon corps avait
laissé comme trace ce stress cette
douleur cette
peur parce que j'étais une enfant
batue
ma mère avait développé des troubles
psychiatriques et elle reportait tout
son mal-être sur ses
enfants en même temps qu'elle m'offrait
la possibilité de restructurer mon corps
pour le valoriser c'est elle qui le
meurtrissait au fil des
années c'est ainsi que pendant mon
enfance et mon adolescence mon corps et
mon âme subissaient de Lourdes traces
visible mais par la danse je l'ai
restauré et je renforçais mon estime ma
force
intérieure ma mère quand elle voulait
nous frapper
elle nous appelait on venait et on se
faisait
frapper un jour elle m'appelle viens là
non viens là je t'ai
dit
non ce jour-là j'ai 15
ans et elle est décidée à me
frapper je cours dans l'appartement je
cours le plus vite possible telle une
gazelle je cours je cours je cours je
cours et elle finit par M' voir mais là
je me défends en la
frappant c'est un jour marquant pour moi
parce que j'ai osé dire stop avec mon
corps mon corps veut vivre il ne veut
plus être meurtri
il devient mon guide mon
appui la danse devient ma force et mon
moyen privilégié pour exprimer mon
identité
qu'est-ce que
danser dites-moi qu'est-ce que
danser
s'exprimer pour moi danser c'est un
processus un processus de
transformation parce que la danse opère
un puissant changement de tout notre
être
elle opère un puissant changement en
nous rendant
tonique
et détendu avec les autres tonique elle
booste notre corps et notre cerveau
expressif en libérant nos potentiels et
détendu avec les autres car elle
améliore nos
relations bref ça nous rent
aide dansons
oui je vous le dis allez-y dansons pour
libérer nos mots et nos gros mots ceux
du quotidien et même les plus
[Musique]
anciens
[Applaudissements]
merci